on the phone line is a gentleman who's
uh i've been saying
pounding this desk we've been on the air
for what six years chris here
correct uh i have been fortunate to be
uh an nfl network uh employee i think i
was like employee number three
being hired there um back in the day um
since 2003 have been at many many pro
football hall of fame
induction ceremonies and one should have
happened obviously
earlier this uh month
but um it was supposed to be the one
with the
you know the huge centennial uh
100th year um 20 members of the
incoming class for 2020 and obviously
due to covet 19 that has been postponed
um and this gentleman didn't hear his
name called again
and i keep saying over and over and over
again this guy deserves
to be in the pro football hall of fame
and
um he heard his name yesterday named
as the finalist for the new category
that's been created for at least the
next four years to try and
make sure that people like him hear
their name called
because they deserve to be enshrined but
sometimes get lost when you're throwing
coaches in in the same category as
players and
contributors owners steve sable as you
know isn't a contributor
uh he's finally heard his name called at
any rate
this gentleman won two super bowls as a
head coach
for the oakland raiders this was after
john madden pro football hall of famer
did it for al davis pro football hall of
famer
also he backed up len dawson as a
quarterback
hall of famer for hank stram hall of
famer
in super bowl four a playing career of
note and then a coaching career
that is hall of fame worthy thrilled to
have the 2021 finalists foreign the pro
football hall of fame in the coaching
category
tom flores here on the rich eisen show
how are you coach
i'm good i'm good thank you very much
yeah i'm just uh
listening to you i'm old enough to
remember alfred newman
i know i wish you had had the probably
uh you
it was training you to have the what me
worry over this very subject for all
those years
um but what what was it like to get this
phone call
uh yesterday to say that you're a
finalist for the pro football hall of
fame and i
i should say that um that
you more often than not usually more
than just usually this does lead to
enshrinement
and getting the uh getting the check
mark from the
committee what was this phone call like
for you tom yesterday well
when it finally happened it was a little
emotional
when it finally happened when i talked
to david baker
because it doesn't really matter when it
matters if you get in
although i've been a little patient and
i've been a little reluctant to
get excited because of what's happened
the last two or three years but
still it looks like this is going to be
it and
i got a little emotional i got tears in
my eyes and
just started thinking about the 60 years
that i spent
in professional football 60
years no question about it who did you
think of anybody in particular
tom no just go back to the first
you know it's interesting i went back to
the first day i did an interview there
was a 1960
santa cruz california first day in the
existence of the oakland raiders
we didn't even know where oakland was at
the time and we were practically we were
having training camp at a high school in
santa cruz
and i'd say well this afl let's see what
happens
where is oakland anyway and
we were played to san francisco and for
two years and
uh we said give it a shot see what
happens i get the rest of my life to
work
doing something else i had a teaching
degree at the time
and uh here we are 61 years later
and um wow a lot of things have happened
first time you met al davis was when tom
flores
63 63 when he came to oakland
and uh he was uh he came from the san
diego chargers with
sid gilman the very first time i met al
it was uh
i liked it i liked what he did i mean we
were
we were introducing 10 minutes later we
were on the on the chalkboard
the target football passing game and it
was fun to talk to him about it because
he was football
football and more football so he uh
taught me a lot
and then he really rescued the raiders
because we were on a dawn spin
so he was uh uh on the on the greece
border was a short passing game right
tom just short passes
just little short passes quickly no no
no
you wanted to go down yeah you wanted to
go downtown boys
he said bold all these little dicks
let's go downtown
i bet i bet so um
so then um getting into uh
coaching um was was it al who called you
to get you into coaching was it madden
who who actually hired you when you were
an assistant for all those years under
madden
for uh as the wide receiver coach and
man the hall of famers that you coached
at that position during that time uh how
did that get started
for you well i i i i
i really didn't want to retire from
plane but that nobody really wanted me
after i left
kansas city so i my first year coaching
actually was with buffalo
as a short time coach just
before the season and then i came back
to california my home
up in the bay area and al and i always
remained
friendships and he always so i called
him and i said i'm looking for something
and you know i'd like to stay in
football if i can
and uh so i'll set up a job uh on
an interview with john madden so i
interviewed with john and and the two of
them
hired me and went to work right away
touching the wide receivers
and hall of fame uh quarterback fred
willinkoff
uh who which i had thrown my his first
pass to
when he was a rookie so i played
i played with fred threw him his first
pass first draw first touchdown came
back coached him
became head coach and cut him
i was about to say you run the gamut tom
flores that's for sure
uh what was it like being interviewed by
john madden for a position
in that room in 1972. pretty casual you
know pretty casual i mean he was
uh he he talked about this and then and
uh we got
on the blackboard a little bit but i
think mostly he wanted
i think i think he realized that going
you know with al's advice because i had
played for al
uh and i knew the system i knew the
offense i knew the raider way
so i think he just wanted to get to know
me because i didn't know john that well
at that point
and uh we we ended up spending uh eight
years
uh and uh and
very close long days long nights
and and through a glorious super bowl
year for him
and so uh when he retired i was
fortunate enough to still be there
and and get the job so it was uh you
know it was
it was we have 19 straight years with
only two coaches
that's pretty rare nowadays no question
about it and so
were you surprised when madden decided
to retire tom and you got the job was
that
did that catch you by surprise is he
such a young man
yeah i was surprised but not totally
because i saw him
uh in agony when he was suffered from an
ulcer that he had and uh
and other things and he had just it was
time
ten years uh it was time for him to step
away and
and she stepped in stepped away big time
he sure did he's i know the crazy thing
is when he finally
when he finally got into the hall people
were wondering did you get in
did he get in as a coach a broadcaster
or a video game impresario you know i
mean he's
yeah he's been something else tom
flory's here on the rich eisen show
super bowls 15 and 18 the winner of
of those two super bowls the the head
coach of the raiders 83 and 53 in the
regular season
including eight and three in the
playoffs on top of all that right here
on on the show um winning that super
bowl
did you realize the momentous moment it
was
for you and for people like you tom
no you don't think about it when when
you're in the middle of the battle and
you're in the middle of
the playoffs and the excitement and the
emotion up and down
the rollercoaster ride i call it uh you
don't think about anything until it's
all over then it's all over you realize
what you've done you said wow
you know that's all you can say is wow
because
what do you do you know now what well
now what is
do it again you have to do it again
because that's that's the life of a
coach
uh you win and then you try to win again
and then you try to win again
and and uh you know i never
dreamed i never dreamed that i'd ever
ever be on that stage in my lifetime
when millions of people all over the
world are watching you
and you're coaching this uh this team
from little oakland
and uh and winning as the first uh
head coach of hispanic descent first
minority uh head coach to win a super
bowl you were also the first
uh hispanic starting quarterback uh in
the national football league do you
think you've blazed a trail tom
well i'd like to think and i didn't take
it at the time but
i didn't realize until later in life
when i was
when i was later in my career she said
when i was traveling around certain
areas
and people would come up of hispanic
background
and i said you know we watched you
coach the super bowl uh
15 or 18 and my dad cried
i said really he said yeah he was so
proud
and i didn't even know the kid the
person's dead
but he was so proud because of what you
did
he cried uh that was pretty special when
you when something like that happens
when you beat the eagles in super bowl
15 and then washington in super bowl 18
were you the one who drew up the marcus
allen pirouette tom was that you
absolutely yeah we we practice that
every day
74 yards later touchdown you're gonna go
down there you're gonna turn around spin
around come back
and then you're going to pick up jim
pluckett as a blocker
and speaking of jim tom it's time to get
him in too don't you think
yeah jim you know he did
he wasn't in a lot of pro bowls uh
you know but he did win two super bowls
he did rookie of the year
and he made big plays with big games so
you know hopefully
at some point in his lifetime you'll
he'll share that experience too well i
mean not many first overall drafted
quarterbacks wind up winning two super
bowls tom i mean it's really kind of
that's simple i mean they're you know
yeah you you could you could really just
you know when somebody comes in with
such hoopla and such um
uh promise from one team winds up with
another and then wins two super bowls
it's quite a story that plunkett has put
together
and one with you too oh yeah i couldn't
be happier for you tom i really couldn't
i mean seriously it just just even uh in
the in the 12 minutes that we've talked
just walking through we didn't even talk
about you being a player
for hank stram and and backing up len
dawson for a super bowl i mean your
football life is something that is so
unique it deserves to be enshrined and i
couldn't be happier for you
well rich i appreciate it thanks for
your support thanks for all the kind
words it's really uh
it's uh it's exciting and uh
i'm not i'm i'm not gonna get too
excited yet because we know i know
a year ago i know this pandemic they
just screwed everything up
well uh i hope you're staying safe and
staying healthy and staying well
best you can tom you too yeah
thanks for the call congrats again for
that that call you got from the hall
you bet thank you that's tom flores hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that
watch more right here